IN PINETAS, THANK YOU.
FOR MORE ON THIS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER DIRECTOR
OF ICE TOM HOMAN, GREAT TO HAVE
YOU IN STUDIO FIRST OF ALL SIT
RIGHT ACROSS FROM EACH OTHER TO
TALK ABOUT THIS SINCE YOU AND I
HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS MORE THAN A MILLION AND A
HALF IMMIGRANTS ACROSS THE
BORDER AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REINSTATING THE
TRUMP-ERA, MPP REMAIN IN MEXICO,
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION, IT WILL
HELP?
>> IT WILL HELP IF THEY DO IT
RIGHT.
WE HAD TO SUE THEM TO DO THAT.
I WAS PART OF THE LAWSUIT.
I FILED MORE AFFIDAVITS SUING
THE PRESIDENT THAN MY WHOLE
CAREER.
WE SUED THEM.
THEY WEREN’T DOING IT SO THE
COURT HAD TO COME BACK AND TELL
THEM, YOU NEED TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN AND MADE ALL OF THE
EXCUSE THAT WE DON’T HAVE THE
PROCESS IN PLACE, WE HAVE TO
START FROM THE GROUND UP AND
MORE AFFIDAVITS FILED UP.
WE’VE ALREADY DONE THIS.
THIS HAS BEEN DONE.
DUST OFF THE PLANE AND START
MAKING WORK.
THEY SAID THEY WERE GOING TO DO
IT.
LET’S BE CLEAR, THEY WERE MADE
TO DO THIS.
THEY DON’T WANT TO DO THIS.
THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO KILL
THE PROGRAM.
IT WON’T BE EFFECTIVE BECAUSE
THEY DON’T WANT IT TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
THEY WANT MORE MIGRANTS TO CROSS
THE BORDER.
THIS IS OPEN BORDERS.
THEY WILL PUSH BACK AND THEY
DON’T SUPPORT IT.
GRIFF: WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
THEY WANT THIS, WHY?
TOM: IN THEIR EYES THIS IS
FUTURE DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
THEY ALSO OVERTURNED TRUMP
CENSUS RULE, THEY WILL BE
COUNTED WHICH IS GOING TO
RESULTS FOR MORE SEATS AND HOUSE
FOR DEMOCRATS.
IN THEIR MINDS THESE ARE FUTURE
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS AND THAT’S WHY
THEY HAVE OPEN BORDERS.
THERE’S NO OTHER REASON TO OPEN
THE BORDER.
THERE’S NO DOWNSIDE OF HAVING A
SECURE BORDER.
GRIFF: IT SEEMS THAT NATIONAL
SECURITY IS REALLY SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE A BIGGER PART
OF THIS CONVERSATION, TOM, AND
IN FULL DISCLOSURE WE TALK OFTEN
ABOUT IT.
I WAS JUST IN PANAMÁ THE LAST
WEEK, FOREIGN MINISTER ERIKA
TELLING TONY GONZALES WHO WAS ON
THE PROGRAM EARLIER THAT SOME 52
KNOWN TERRORIST INDIVIDUALS
CROSSED THAT DANGEROUS JUNGLE
WHERE I WAS AND IT’S THIS
PIPELINE, TOM, THAT RUNS FROM
SOUTH AMERICA ALL THE WAY TO OUR
BORDER IN TEXAS WHERE YOU ARE
SEEING THERE YOU CAN SEE THE
BOAT, THOSE MIGRANTS, MOST OF
THEM HAITIANS, THEY ARE COMING
ACROSS THE JUNGLE AND THEN THEY
ARE BEING TAKEN TO A LITTLE TOWN
CALLED LAS BLANCAS AND GO 12
STRAIGHT HOURS DIRECTLY TO COSTA
RICAN BORDER AND BE LET OUT TO
CONTINUE THEIR JOURNEY YET THIS
HAS IMPLICATIONS OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LET’S BE CLEAR, THERE IS NO
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THERE IS NO HOMELAND SECURITY.
WITHOUT BORDER SECURITY.
THAT’S JUST COMMON SENSE.
AS I’VE SAID FOR MONTHS, THIS IS
A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS
BECAUSE HALF OF THE BORDER
PATROL IS OFF THE LINE TAKING
CARE OF LARGE GROUPS, THAT’S
WHEN THE CARTEL USE OPEN BORDERS
TO MOVE DRUGS, TO MOVE GANG
MEMBERS AND TO MOVE SUSPECTED
TERRORISTS.
THE GAP FOR THE LAST DECADE HAS
BEEN A MAJOR ROLE FOR KNOWN
SUSPECTED TERRORISM --
TERRORISTS TO COME THROUGH
THERE.
WE’VE ACTUALLY -- WHEN I WAS ICE
DIRECTOR WE HAD AGENTS DOWN
THERE WORKING WITH THE
PANAMENIAN GOVERNMENT, WERE IN
THE GAP AND MADE THE JOURNEY AND
FINAL DESTINATION, MANY OF THEM
WAS THE UNITED STATES.
YOU HAVE GREAT COVERS DOWN THERE
AND PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND,
THERE’S TENS OF THOUSANDS PEOPLE
COMING THROUGH THE DARING GAP,
SUSPECTED TERRORISTS WILL EMBED
THEMSELVES IN THE GROUP.
GRIFF: WE HAVE TO LEAVE THE
CONVERSATION THERE BUT WHEN I
WAS THERE THEY HAD A DEPARTMENT
OF STATE SECRETARY ROSEA MEETING
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND MAYBE
THEY WILL DO SOMETHING DOWN
THERE TO STOP IT BEFORE IT COMES